qui croisent un pote et les deux grosses
valises dans la main dis que tu branles
avec tes valises bah il dit tu devineras
jamais bah dis vas-y balance il dit quoi
bah dis donc dans cette valise là il y a
une un génie et l'autre tu dis tu
déconnes vas-y vas-y ouvre là tu vois
qu'il ouvre la valise
un génie de 20 m de haut qui sort du
haut tu m'as libéré
fais un
vœu Elodie dépêche-toi
parce qu'après il disparaît c'est
terminé et ben il dit que je dis vas-y
mannequin ça va se terminer il dit je
veux un milliard
la valise se referme et bah
il y a un billard
un 3 mètres 80 tu sais le billard breton
à trois boules qui tombent juste à côté
de lui
et le Didier il dit il y a quoi dans
l'eau de valise il m'a dit de l'eau de
valise il y a une une mite géante
hello pour voir hello et là il y a une
mite
de 20 kg dans la vallée
mais dis attends ton génie là quand même
un petit problème de d'oreille il est
comme notre copain je lui demande un
milliard il me donne un billard bah oui
et moi tu crois que j'ai demandé une
grosse mute
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais dire un truc sur les
punaises je peux la punaise n'a pas
d'orifice sexuel non on n'est pas là
pour ça
non mais c'est suffisamment curieux pour
pouvoir le raconter alors
le mal
et se percer la carapace je vais dire
faut pas y aller avec une demi molle
tu prends ton élan et bah et il fait un
trou dans la carapace
[Applaudissements]
dis donc j'ai été voir Jocelyne on a bu
un thé non tourne-toi c'est quoi le trou
là